Diese neue Technologie könnte wirklich eine
Revolution sein!
Ein Forschungsteam vom renommierten Massachusetts
Institute of Technology (MIT) hat jetzt eine
Technik entwickelt, mit der sich Schaltungen
oder kleine Sensoren ihren Strom quasi aus
der Luft holen könnten.
Konkret geht es um eine Art Antenne, die aus
WiFi-Funkwellen eine autonome Stromversorgung
ermöglicht.
Können wir demnächst Smartphone und Co also
einfach über das WLAN aufladen?
Clixoom Science & Fiction - Hier gibt es täglich
faszinierende Wissenschaftsvideos.
Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann und nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts herzlich willkommen!
Inzwischen ist es ja leichter ein Wlan-Netz
zu finden als eine Steckdose.
Wie genial wäre es denn, wenn die elektromagnetischen
Wellen eines WLAN-Netzwerkes nicht nur zur
Datenübertragung nutzbar wären, sondern
gleichzeitig unsere Geräte wie Handy oder
Tablet auch mit Strom versorgen würden?!
Ganz nach dem Motto: “Tschüss, Ladekabel”.
Genau solch eine Technik hat jetzt ein internationales
Forschungsteam entwickelt - zumindest in Form
eines Prototypen.
Konkret geht es um eine sogenannte “Rectenna.
Im Englischen “rectifying antenna”, was
so viel heißt wie gleichrichtende Antenne.
In der Fachsprache ist damit eine Schaltungsanordnung
gemeint, die hochfrequente elektromagnetische
Wellen empfangen und diese dann in eine Gleichspannung
umwandeln kann.
Vielleicht klingelt es an dieser Stelle bei
denjenigen von Euch, die sich noch an die
sogenannten “Kristallradios” erinnern,
die auf einem ähnlichen Prinzip basierten.
Diese speziellen Radiogeräte aus den Anfängen
des Rundfunkes bestanden nur aus sehr wenigen
Bauteilen und basierten auf einer einfachen
Technik.
Sie wandelten nämlich elektromagnetische
Schwingungen von Radiowellen in ein hörbares
Signal um - und zwar über einen Gleichrichter.
Sie
kamen also ohne eigene Stromversorgung aus
- unter der Voraussetzung, dass die Sender
stark genug waren!
Theoretisch gesehen könnte man auch heutzutage
Wellen von Mobilfunk- oder WiFi-Sendern anzapfen
- davon gibt es ja reichlich.
Doch mangelte es bisher an geeigneten Materialien,
die auch für tragbare elektronische Geräte
eingesetzt werden könnten.
Eine solche drahtlose Form der Energieübertragung
wird ja auch bei RFID-Chips genutzt, doch
auch hier sind diese “gleichrichtenden Antennen”
aus dickem und unflexiblem Material.
Dies ist bei der neu entwickelten “Rectenna”
des MIT-Forschungsteams anders: Die Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftler haben für den Bau ihres
Prototypen das Hochleistungs-Material namens
Molybdändisulfid (MoS2) genutzt.
Es entsteht bei der Reaktion von Schwefel
mit Molybdänoxid und fungiert als Elektronenleiter.
Wohl einer der dünnsten Halbleiter weltweit,
der sich schichtweise herstellen lässt.
Und das ist wirklich krass: Die so konstruierte
Antenne ist nur noch drei Atome dick und somit
unglaublich flexibel.
Zudem kann sie auch großflächig produziert
werden.
So wandelt die Rectenna das Wechselstromsignal
der WLAN-Netzwerke in eine Gleichspannung
um.
Und genau diese ist in der Lage elektronische
Schaltungen zu betreiben oder Batterien aufzuladen.
War die neu entwickelte Rectenna mit Wi-Fi-Signalen
von etwa 150 Mikrowatt umgeben - was eine
durchaus typische Leistung ist -, konnte die
Antenne eine Leistung von etwa 40 Mikrowatt
erzeugen.
Damit kann zwar kein Tablet am Laufen gehalten
werden, doch die Beleuchtung eines gewöhnlichen
Handy-Displays gelingt damit.
Das Forschungsteam selbst setzt große Hoffnungen
in diese Technologie.
Denn sie könnte für allerhand Anwendungen
spannend sein.
Beispielsweise in der medizinischen Diagnostik,
in der Minigeräte Daten aus dem Körper-Inneren
der Patienten funken.
Im Vergleich zu Batterien, die in diesem Kontext
ein gesundheitliches Risiko darstellen, würde
eine solch dünne Elektronik kaum Volumen
darstellen.
Aber auch Bauwerke könnten in Regionen, die
erdbeben-gefährdet sind, durch zahlreiche
Sensoren in ihrer Stabilität überwacht werden.
Dazu Tomás Palacios, einer der beteiligten
Forscher: “Damit lässt sich eine breite
Palette an Sensoren für die Umweltüberwachung
oder die chemische und biologische Sensorik
entwerfen, die auf der Basis von nur einem
Mikrowatt arbeiten.
Oder Sie speichern den Strom in einer Batterie,
die Sie später nutzen können.“
Fest steht: Diese Idee, Signale aus der Luft
zur Stromgewinnung zu nutzen, ist nicht neu.
Auch andere Forschungsteam tüfteln an der
Umsetzung.
Beispielsweise hat Apple im Frühling 2017
ein Patent für eine Technologie angemeldet,
die den Router als Ladestation und WiFi als
Energiequelle nutzt.
Da haben wir also noch eine Menge zu erwarten.
Und auch in diesem Bereich machen eben neue
Werkstoffe Dinge möglich, die früher unmöglich
erschienen und wer weiß, vielleicht könnte
die Energie aus Wlan-Netzwerken demnächst
Handys zumindest in ausgeschaltetem Zustand
langsam laden.
Allein das wäre ein riesiger Fortschritt.
Unsichtbar durch Zeitlöcher?
Geht das?
Auf dieses Video klicken, wenn ihr diese Frage
von Neugierzone beantwortet haben wollt.
Auch extrem spannendes Video.
Abonnieren nicht vergessen und ansonsten:
Bis dann, bleibt dran!